[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan we all like
surprises right
surprise what'd you get me
well
it's an unwelcome surprise ryan
isn't that funny right because
if something is an unwelcome surprise we
call it a disruption we call it a
disturbance
we call it an annoyance yeah we don't
usually call it a surprise
right yeah that's what i want to talk to
you about on today's public episode
we're gonna talk about surprise
purchases slash
annoying
purchases
and then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
talk to listeners about the occasions
when their spouses
children
parents and roommates have made
purchases without telling them we have a
lot of fun examples with this yeah you
can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements
suck
ryan our first question today is from
forest on facebook
what's the difference between surprise
purchases and impulse purchases to me
they're the same and should be avoided
at all costs pun intended
hello good pun
you know ryan it's um
i want to i don't want to get bogged
down in definition so if you are annoyed
by a surprise purchase then it's an
annoying purchase if you're annoyed by
an impulse purchase then you know
but what is it what does the purchase
make you feel if i go back to
when we were kids i think about ella all
the time now she
if she gets something and she's
surprised by it it was like all this
overwhelming sort of
joy
right but if she's annoyed by something
there's also this overwhelming annoyance
by you know if the thing broke or the
thing isn't working the way that the the
toy runs out of batteries
it's really easy to get frustrated and
so maybe
maybe they actually are the same thing
maybe a surprise any surprise is also an
annoyance
on some spectrum
yeah
it could be so it's the uh the the
difference between
an impulse right
and an annoying purchase or a surprise
purchase well i mean a surprise purchase
is unplanned like that is yeah so um
yeah you know your transmission goes out
like that's i mean maybe it's impulsive
because you have to fix transmission to
get your car to work so you get from
point a to point b it's definitely
reactive yes but but when i think of
impulse purchases i think about like
when you're in the checkout line and you
see
you know
the little plastic toys that i have to
really talk myself out of buying yeah
but uh but yeah i mean that's that's
more of an impulsive thing not as much
as a surprise so
for me the difference would be
a surprise purchase is unavoidable
an impulse purchase is typically
avoidable
right right and so
i guess it really depends what we mean
by a surprise here too right because the
impulse purchase what a great point ryan
if you're in the checkout line and all
of a sudden oh i should get this candy
bar i should get this pack of gum i
should buy this tchotchke whatever it is
there's this thing that i wasn't
planning on buying i didn't come to the
store for this
but since i see it now i'm going to buy
it the biggest problem here is now we're
constantly at the store because it's in
our pocket
and so you're scrolling through
instagram and that ad for those shoes or
that t-shirt or that dress or that hat
pops up in your instagram feed
and you say oh yeah i and we tell
ourselves a story i've been meaning to
get that or oh i think that looks great
it's beautiful i would look great in
that now all of a sudden it is an
impulse purchase or it's on sale oh i
have to get it because it's on sale
right not to get it right
and i don't want to waste this
opportunity to to save 30 percent well
it's this opportunity
well here's the thing it's 100 off if
you don't buy it yeah and and so yes i'm
i'm with you man there are some rules we
have so we have this minimalist rule
book forest you can download it the
minimalists.com
resources we have a bunch of free
resources over there including the 16
rules for living with less it's a free
ebook you can download one of the rules
in there that will help you is called
the wait for it rule yeah and this just
goes hey if something costs more than 30
and you can adjust that number but for
me it's 30 bucks i try to wait 30 hours
i call the 30 30 rule right yeah it's
basically like hey if there's anything
that's even a remotely substantial
purchase let me wait a day or so
hence the 30 30 rule because quite often
instead of if i'm scrolling through that
instagram feed oh yeah i really would
like those shoes
then i wait a day
i always think oh is that do i really
want to spend
79 and which by the way
79 this might be a cheap pair of shoes
i'm wait
should i google this company i've never
even heard of this company maybe they're
a scam maybe they make really poor
quality stuff with really great
advertisements it looks really shiny the
facade is but there's nothing inside
maybe it's actually a piece of junk and
i think many of our impulse purchases
and then by proxy many of our surprise
purchases
are
junk
yeah it's interesting because i it has
me thinking that surprise purchases
something like the 30 30 rule may not
work because going back to that
transmission thing it's like you're not
going to wait 30 hours right to be like
well do i need my car or not like it's
probably something you have to take care
of as soon as possible yes um so again i
just to highlight the difference between
the surprise purchase and uh yeah and an
impulse purchase i'll tell you what man
it's kind of scary like where we're
going with shopping so you mentioned
uh how you know we have a shop we have a
shopping cart in our pocket
yeah we were just one click away from
buying so many things
and what i worry about um i don't know
if you've seen like face or i guess meta
whatever facebook meta verse whatever
you want to call it they just launched
their
virtual reality shopping store like it
so maybe it's in beta testing but i've
heard about it yeah it's it's uh it's in
i guess it's a walmart technically
and oh really yeah so like i just i
don't know man that's where it's going
and we can't stop it right and uh
that's okay like i'm not against
you know advancements in technology
um
but but you know that's that's why we
talk about the conversations we have is
because it's not gonna get better it's
it's only going to get
worse it's only gonna get more tempting
yeah and yeah we've gotta we've we've
gotta have some of those boundaries put
in place otherwise
um
yeah we will
give in to these impulses yes yeah i
look at surprise purchases as though
there's there's two different kinds
really and there may be more than two
but there's the kind where like the
transmission like oh god i
that's a terrible surprise i'm annoyed
by it right and then there's these
surprise purchases that are thrust upon
you onto you by other people right and
so maybe it's someone you're living with
they come home with the
with whatever purchase for the home hey
look i bought a new couch
all of a sudden you'd be surprised yeah
now now for some people it could be like
oh my god we've been talking for a while
we've really wanted a new couch i
surprised you with one but for the most
part
if someone
bombards you
barges into your home
and reverse shoplifts something into
your home
i i for me there's there's nothing you
could bring into my home
that i can think of
that would add immense value to my life
unless i was already thinking about
getting it i because
and a surprise for me i didn't make that
decision intentionally even if you give
me a surprise party which sounds like a
nightmare for me
it
i i don't ever want to be surprised and
so i get that some people have a value
system where they're like oh yes it's
really great i want you to surprise me i
i enjoy the spontaneity and i'm all for
being spontaneous in fact with my wife
every other wednesday we take the day
off
and this coming wednesday we're going to
do this and
we will spontaneously pick a place to go
and it could be hey we're going to go to
venice and go to the beach hey we're
going to go up to malibu creek state
park and we're going to hang out there
for the day and just walk in the sun
or maybe we're going to go to a movie or
maybe we're going to go to a
neighborhood we've never been to before
and explore it's a spontaneous and it is
a surprise to us it's always surprising
but it's almost like planned
surprise planned spontaneity
that is so joshua fields milburn right
and and but
because here's the thing i've set my
life up in a way ryan
where
i do about three or four different
things regularly
and that's all that i do right and then
occasionally we'll go out and we'll try
something
new but i've also figured out quite
often what i like what adds value to my
life what things add value to my life
what activities add value to my life
what types of people add value to my
life and and the amount what's the
because i get a men's value from ryan's
in my relationship
but if we were spending 24 hours to
gather every day i would get far less
value which is the same thing with our
stuff we were just talking to a reporter
before this for the columbus dispatch
and which is the the newspaper in
columbus ohio and the thing that i was
talking to to him about ryan
was
that uh as a minimalist it's a paradox i
get far more value
from my things today
than
before i i was a minimalist
when i had so many things
but i didn't get a whole lot of value
and then the value sort of per capita
the value per item is so much more
because i don't have all these surprises
i know
what i get value from and so no i'm not
against surprises but i think the truth
is if we're not intentional about the
things that we let into our lives the
things we bring into our lives then we
let anything in and it ends up being an
annoyance for us let's move on to our
callers ryan if you have a question or
comment for our podcast give us a call
406 219 7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
we have a question here from christy in
st louis i was just at work reading a
bunch of articles about amazon's new
products that they're releasing like the
echo microwave and
alexa in your car and everything and it
was just mind-blowing to me that
our society has become lazy enough to
where we don't even want to press
buttons to cook a potato we have to have
a voice
to cook our potatoes so i was wondering
what your guys's thoughts on that is
because to me it's mind-blowing and
everybody seemed super excited about it
but i just
can't believe this is where we came at
society alexa kill ryan nicodemus
calling ryan nicodemus
i'm foiled again
oh man cooking a potato
with your voice
it's man it sounds it sounds like there
are probably
some exceptions where this might be
really useful for some but i do agree
that like we are heading towards this
wall-e
type dystopia so the the movie wall-e
where yeah there's a robot and humans
have basically got to a point where
they're just kind of hovering around in
this entertainment chair
that feeds them and and they watch tv
and like they don't move and none of
them can can walk because they have
evolved
uh to just be you know fat and lazy
basically
and it is disturbing man but like i said
you know like i said earlier
we can't stop it
it's coming yeah and if we allow it to
it will take over our lives
and right now though right now we have
the opportunity
to start setting up some boundaries to
start behaving in a way that we won't be
taken over by those things
um the the vr stuff is really i'm like
50 passionate about it because i know
that like this is going to be the next
kind of wave of technology and i think
there will be some cool stuff like i
would love
um you know to go hiking up count mount
kilimanjaro
without actually having to hike it
and you could put on a vr headset i
think they actually do have some similar
stuff like this or even better i was
thinking about um
if you uh
if you can like have a company that
basically i'm giving away i'm giving
away my million dollar ideas here but if
you could have a like a tourist company
where you're like oh i want to go to
shanghai yeah but i want to do it from
my you know my home
then you could have someone with a
camera walking around you could put your
vr headset on and maybe direct them
where to go oh that looks like a nice
whatever let's go in there let's go to
this museum yeah whatever it may be so i
think there's some really cool
things that are around the corner with
vr but the other 50 percent of me is
very worried like christy is here like
it's going to
oh my god as soon as they can like
simulate sex it's over yeah
it's over but even things that are much
more sort of banal
i mean i saw what's the ces consumer
electronics
show um out in vegas i saw a video from
that recently and there was this company
that just made doors that open on their
own in front of you like when you go to
the grocery store you know how the the
door just slides open in front of you
yeah well it's just regular doors in
your home now so the door to your
bedroom you can walk in front of it and
it just opens and my first thought is oh
that's so cool but i'm like
josh you can't turn a knob
like by the way i'd barely ever even
shut my bedroom door why would i want to
like decrease the airflow in my home and
now but it looks cool oh it's very star
trek-esque and so i'm with you christy i
i i totally get that it's like hey where
are we going with this do we really need
that but here's what i'll say there are
a lot of things you're used to using
right now that people said the same
thing about if people are getting so
lazy they can't even wash their clothes
by hand anymore right you have to have a
washing machine yeah what is wrong with
people this was the conversation was
going on a generation or two ago right
yeah and we have a friend leo babalta
his whole family uses a washing machine
to wash their clothes he washes his
clothes in the sink still just to prove
that he can
you know get by with very little he can
live simply yeah he doesn't need to hop
on the hedonic treadmill and so a lot of
these things like i have a dishwasher in
our apartment i've never used it once
a lot of people use their dishwasher
every day and that's okay it's fine
but i don't use it i prefer to wash the
dishes on my own i prefer to open my own
doors and not have siri do it i
but there are other things where it is
convenient if i want to say
you know hey what's the popul hey siri
what's the population of omaha nebraska
i can figure that out relatively quickly
and i think that is a convenience thing
that is helpful now
net net is it positive
depends on who you are for some people
it's a giant net negative because it's
taking all of our time all of our
attention it's a gigantic distraction
that 79th organ that is in our pocket or
now just in our hands
we're walking around like zombies
staring at these glowing screens
and so
is our technology improving our lives
yes but
who said that we need to improve our
lives
and that's
we often think that improving our lives
is a good thing but improving our lives
simply means improving it that's not
inherently good if what if we improve
our lives so much that we lose the
essence of who we are we lose the
struggle we lose the friction that makes
us human and so christie what you're
talking about is
these tech companies are removing a lot
of the friction from our lives
which sounds great at first
but when you take away all the friction
you lose traction you go careening from
side to side you're going to fall into
whatever ditch is over there because
you're not able to sort of keep your
vehicle on the road yeah
well all these technologies man they're
tools like they're
[Music]
and a tool is as good as its user yeah
so you know we have to just be careful
with these tools that we pick up and be
careful with how we use them but
you know are we are we going to sit here
and promote um what would it
we're not luddites wha what is it led
ism yeah
yeah so we're not going to promote
luddite-ism
but we will promote intentionality and
that's what we have to do with these
technologies we have to be intentional
with them yeah yeah so the la the
original luddites were were people
during the industrial revolution who
tried to destroy the machines oh wow and
and so they were called the luddites
right and so like they would try to
destroy any any machine that was they
were just against advancement yes yeah
and there are there's a whole neo
luddite movement
and they have a lot to recommend it
makes a whole lot of sense because it is
disconnecting us from our humanity but
you're right the broad sweeping well
let's just blow it all up is also not
the answer now ryan is absolutely right
these are tools these they're they're
different tools now because unlike a
hammer a hammer was not
engineered by large teams of people to
distract you 24 hours a day seven days a
week
and so we have to be cognizant of the
goals of the technologists of the
manufacturers of the people who are
trying to aggregate our eyeballs our
attention onto products and services
because they don't use the hammer to
sell carpenters a whole bunch of
different things but our phone is right
there in our hand all the time trying to
sell us inadequacy
make us feel inadequate therefore you'll
buy the product or service the the hair
replacement product or the erectile
dysfunction pill
or the
the uh sleeping
supplements or whatever it might be
because if you just buy this thing
then you'll be more complete if you just
upgrade your technology then you'll be
more complete dude
i'm going to interrupt you guys for just
a second off mike
uh
we're looking at this from the lens of
able-bodied people too
so to keep in mind that some of these
technologies like opening the door
somebody that doesn't have the
capability yeah
yeah that's yeah so so uh podcast sean
is talking about how
uh someone who is in his abled body like
opening a door for them so kind of like
i said at the very beginning of this
there are certain situations where this
is totally going to be uh going to be
useful for people it's going to be a
game changer so is the microchip that
elon musk is trying to put in our brains
in fact he is specifically looking at um
like quadriplegics who who can uh do
certain things just by thinking so yes
certainly there's always there's always
going to be an exception and uh this
could be game changer for for people in
those types of situations totally agree
podcast on i'll tell you one thing that
drives me crazy though i cannot turn off
the one-click purchasing when i buy a
book i don't know why that is i have
googled it i have like tried i've turned
off one-click purchasing on amazon but
like for whatever reason dude like they
do not let you turn it off like when
you're buying an audiobook or when
you're buying a book and it's like one
of the most frustrating things because i
hate doing the one-click purchasing i'm
probably going to hit you know add to
cart and then check out but the fact
that i don't even have the option like
they're just they're taking away as much
friction as possible man right yeah it's
uh yeah we get yeah you got to be
careful though they're
they want all your money they want all
your time they want all your attention
you're being programmed to consume right
and you are being programmed
for convenience yeah now as podcast sean
brings up yeah of course there are some
applications medical applications
um and other applications for our
technology that save lives and
even the playing field for everyone and
that's beautiful we were up in seattle
recently we had a tour stop up there and
i was at this coffee shop and they had
you know a stairway and there was a
person who came in on a
in an electronic wheelchair but they
also had a one of those little elevators
that brings them from one floor to
another right
and that meant they were able to sit in
the restaurant literally right next to
where i was and they wouldn't have been
able to do so without that right
advancement so those things are
wonderful the problem we run into
is when we
prioritize convenience over everything
else our lives become imminently
convenient
but they start to lose the meaning
because well we're just doing things
because they're easy yeah
we're not doing things to simplify our
lives necessarily yeah and just to
really reiterate this conversation we're
having we're not putting a judgment on
these things no these aren't good or bad
they just are
and uh i just want to be clear with that
like this isn't saying like oh if you
get one of those automatic doors you're
a bad person and you're lazy and you're
not a minimalist that's not what we're
saying yeah no well but here's the other
thing maybe you are lazy
and i'm not saying that's a bad thing
either i i'm lazy sometimes too right
it's not
we're all lazy with respect to something
not everyone there's one jocko willink
in the world and he's like getting up at
4 30 and and conquering the world or
whatever right but like yeah sometimes
we sleep in is that lazy okay fine
as soon as you remove all even the
judgment out of something like that is
yes
me microwaving something as opposed to
cooking it in the oven
is lazy
and it's okay to do it as well um
voice activated potato
christie even henry david thoreau the
sort of the the epitome
of
of self-reliance his mother did his
laundry for him when he was living out
on walden pond so just keep that in mind
i'm gonna send you a copy of our book
everything that remains
it's a book ryan and i wrote almost a
decade ago now ryan how crazy is that
man actually the first draft was written
this year and uh
well 10 years ago this year uh 20 2012.
and uh it was the the thing that really
took off for us and a lot of people
found value in that book it was this
journey of these two suit and tie
corporate guys becoming minimalist and
eventually the minimalists and the
boston globe called it like henry david
thoreau but with wi-fi
and so if you enjoy the podcast you'll
enjoy the audiobook version of
everything that remains it's still our
most popular book to date or if you want
the book book or the ebook version of
everything that remains we'll send that
to you as well christy
alabama do we have any questions or
comments from the live stream yet no
questions just yet but we do have plenty
of warm greetings from denmark
california louisiana australia chile
ohio and a special hello from our emma
the immigrant over in canada
emma outstanding hey emma beautiful well
everyone else we'll get to much more
from the live stream during the maximal
episode this thursday over on patreon
but ryan in the meantime what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the landing round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
937-202-4654 now during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all our minimal maximums in one
place
minimalmaxims.com thanks to our good
friend jessica lynn williams social jess
looks like shannon has a question for us
alabama
my ex-husband used to come home with big
purchases without ever consulting me how
can we get our partners to include us in
the buying process i think shannon took
the the advice that you give about you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you
considering this is her ex-husband it
sounds like she uh
took that advice i'm imagine what the
big purchases are but they're like it's
just like this giant foam hand from a
get like they're just really big things
that he brought home right um what are
some things and we're going to talk
about this a bit uh some purchases that
annoyed us on the maximal episode
because we've had partners significant
others spouses friends family who have
given us surprises
that have really annoyed us but let's
let's talk to shannon here specifically
and i think what she realized here's my
pithy answer we can we can unpack it
to be on the same page you must first
read from the same book
now
i think with shannon what she realized
is they just weren't reading from the
same book right
but sometimes it's okay to be on
different pages
because that just means that you have
different preferences you have different
abilities you have different time frames
you have different pace
than someone else so you're not always
going to be exactly on the same page i
love this analogy because i'm a slow
reader
so uh mariah's a little bit faster than
me so if we're reading out of the same
book
um yeah she's gonna get to page 50
before i before i am however
maybe we have you know a conversation at
page 50
and so we kind of have some patience for
one another
to uh to you know to make sure that
we've read everything then we can have a
conversation rather than her being on
page 50 and being like why aren't you
here yet career breed yeah yeah and then
if you were to extend that if she were
saying hey let's talk after page 50 and
you're like okay but then you go off and
read a different book and you're like
all right now i'm on page 50 i'm ready
to talk to you yeah
you're not going to be communicating
right and and so
i think that's the key here what i'm
really saying is if you don't have
similar values then one of you is going
to get dragged in a different direction
yeah and it's not going to feel good for
either party by the way absolutely
absolutely
my pet the answer is this compassion is
key to understanding others so
if you have a spouse that is going out
and making
surprise purchases or annoying purchases
instead of you know judging them
uh instead of yelling at them or making
them feel bad
approach it with compassion and this is
this is really good advice for a lot of
difficult conversations for conflict uh
we were talking about conflict at our
los angeles event a couple nights ago
and uh when you approach conflict
with compassion it's so much easier to
get somewhere that both people want to
be so
uh how do you approach someone with
compassion is buying purchases get to
the understanding of why why do they a
why do they feel compelled to buy these
purchases and b why do they feel
not compelled to talk to you about it
getting to those questions is is gonna
help now there's no magic spell that you
can you know put on your partner there's
no uh uh you know tweetable answer josh
and i can give that's gonna just all of
a sudden make your partner do everything
that you want them to do
but you know uh that that's okay because
a relationship especially a romantic
relationship it's about the give and the
take there is no such thing in my i mean
maybe there is an exception to this
right but
a perfect relationship doesn't exist
right and if i actually
you know somehow could date a female
version of myself that would probably be
miserable too
so so uh you know appreciating these
differences
and and looking at this as an
opportunity to strengthen the
relationship like that's going to be so
much more powerful than just scalding
a partner who
came home with a bowling ball that said
homer on it yes
yeah and so when you're talking about
compassion what we're really talking
about is seeing the suffering in someone
else and being with them for that right
yeah and so that that's literally what
compassion means it means with suffering
that's the the sort of latin root of
compassion and so what ryan is saying
here is to understand them you want to
understand their suffering their pain
points because what led to that big
purchase you know if your ex-husband
bought a ten thousand dollar watch and
you are struggling to pay the rent and
he's like oh i put two thousand dollars
down and now i'm paying eight grand over
the next 36 months or something
these things happen in fact ryan when
we're out on tour i've been reading this
section from our latest book love people
use things about this couple in
minneapolis who
were their relationship was really
ruined and i talk about they have all
these money problems their sex life was
non-existent
they were bickering over small things
but then ultimately
they hid purchases for each from each
other yeah and as soon as i read that
line the whole crowd gets real silent
like uh-oh
and i think that's the thing that the
hiding something from other people means
i'm ashamed of who i am i'm ashamed of
doing this i'm ashamed of what you might
think of me
and so it shows a lack of compassion in
the relationship if i'm ashamed to admit
my mistake or my preferences or my
values or my desires if i have shame
around that
well then
well
it makes it difficult for me to
communicate with the person that i love
but if you can show up and say hey look
there's no shame here
i understand that you're suffering i'm
suffering there's some suffering behind
this because i actually see both sides
of
of this with shannon i also understand i
don't want to get permission from my
wife to purchase something
but i all i do talk to her about anytime
we're going to bring something into the
house we we have a rule together before
we bring any new purchase into the house
we're going to agree on it together it's
not that i need her permission
but i don't want to bombard her with
surprise purchases yeah
ryan we got a bunch more to talk about
but first real quick right here right
now one thing going on in the life of
the minimalist we're the only podcast
that i know of that doesn't ask this
every episode you know people like and
subscribe and hit the bell notifications
and
no no you do whatever you want to do if
you like it you subscribe
you know how to you can figure all that
out but once a year in fact last year we
forgot to ask about this we recorded an
episode that never came out and so we we
were going to ask this last year so we
asked literally once or twice a year
if you'd be willing to give us an annual
performance review um head on over to
apple podcasts uh i think it's just
apple dot or applepodcast.com the
minimalists even if you don't listen to
this podcast on apple podcast this helps
us reach more people if you listen to
this podcast or view this podcast on
youtube would you be willing for two
minutes today right now to pause the
podcast and leave us an honest review
because that allows us to reach more
ears more eyes it gets our simple living
message into more homes there's no
advertisements we're 100 advertisement
free and we don't come on here every
episode asking you to like and subscribe
and click here and do this and once a
year would you be willing to leave us a
review if it's five stars wonderful if
it's not totally understand as well if
it's one star why the hell are you still
listening
[Music]
but uh we would really appreciate it so
if you'd be willing just go to
applepodcast.com
the minimalist or open up your apple
podcast app and type in the minimalist
leave us a rating and a review that
would help us out a lot and you won't
hear about this next week or the week
after that or the week after that this
is the one time we're gonna ask so now
is the time to do it
alabama what do you got for us here are
some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hey guys this is nikki from mount
pleasant south carolina i just listened
to your podcast called media and i
actually have an app recommendation
i do have an android but i'm pretty sure
there's an ios and iphone app out there
that's similar
it's called app detox and i love it
because it allows you to restrict and
even block access to apps on your phone
so i personally use it for facebook and
instagram
and i allow myself a 30 minute time
limit each day
but at times especially when i find
myself getting lost in the infinite
scroll of the news feeds i'll actually
block access completely so i think that
it has added a lot of value to my life
and i think it can add value to a lot of
other listeners lives as well
i wanted to call in to share a recent
revelation that i had which has removed
numerous roadblocks i've come up against
on my quest for a more minimalist
lifestyle the public library
i hadn't been to the public library
since about high school and i can't
believe i had forgotten all of the free
resources available at my local library
that previously i had been routinely and
wastefully paying for
movies and movie rentals magazines
magazine subscriptions books
many of which if i decided to purchase
and not rent lingered around in my house
collecting dust until i got around to
minimizing them
even the due date on the materials i get
from the library now is helpful
it motivates me to complete the book or
magazine in a timely manner allowing me
to fit in more information over time
which i enjoy since i tend to mow these
through those items if i own them my
interest often grows cold
i'm saving even by having a quiet
well-lighted location with plenty of
space and outlets to do work something i
had actually been paying money for by
working in places like starbucks or
barnes and noble where i felt pressured
to purchase a coffee or snack in
exchange for the work location
i don't have those pressures at the
library which is good for my wallet and
my health
in fact i realized i was actually losing
money by not using the library since the
tax dollars that i necessarily pay were
going towards the upkeep of the library
which i was not utilizing
i encourage i encourage all those who
are looking for a more minimalist
lifestyle but who don't want to
sacrifice the luxury of indulging in
printed or digital media in a pleasant
workspace outside of the home to
rediscover their public library and
other free offerings in their community
something that's simple and easy
all right ryan so this is really what
the added value segments for i'm going
to get to this added value here in a
moment because
i just did something redid something
that added immense value to my life over
the course of the last year and i want
to share it with you i want to share
with the audience because i think you
might get value from it as well but
first here is a
kind testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon supporters this is from ray
hamilton
she says after a year of listening to
the minimalists i'm starting to better
understand my values and i'm learning to
prioritize my mental health and
relationships
i was fresh out of college working two
jobs a low-grade hoarder
straight out of a toxic relationship and
had more issues than i could name since
then i've rearranged what i focus on
simplified my life cut out unhealthy
friends and prioritized my mental health
so here i am a new private podcast
member to support the people who taught
me so much and continue learning how to
choose myself over society's
expectations oh ray wow thank you so
much and ray thank you for using an
oxford comma i really appreciate that
sean has a whole box of them
he traded them for one m dash though
[Laughter]
ray thank you so much we're grateful
that you are one of our patreon
supporters every week we do a long form
maximal episode they're completely
separate from this minimal episode we we
let our hair down roll up our sleeves
and other mixed metaphors
it really is the private space we're
able to have some more in-depth more
open conversations but for added value
this week ryan
over the last year
bex and i re-watched my favorite tv show
she had never seen it i hadn't seen it
in about 20 years yeah so the pilot
actually came out
20 years ago next month oh wow it's
called the shield yeah great show
there's seven seasons of it and i got to
tell you that
it first aired in 2002 and then it aired
for the next seven seasons and so it has
been off the air for like what almost 15
years at this point
and
i
realized it's simultaneously
timeless
and it's also quintessentially audi's it
takes place in that period where flip
phones were ubiquitous oh right it's in
los angeles so i saw it completely
differently because i had never even
been to los angeles the first time i
watched this whole series and i also
watched it differently i watched it over
the course of seven years every tuesday
night at 10 p.m on fx
commercials and all yeah
and and now
i went back and watched it we'd watch a
couple a week and that's why and
sometimes toward the end we were
watching more than that but um
it was also a show that was before
social media and it was a popular it was
a hit show but i think it would have
been like the biggest show in the world
if social media would have been around
at the time
because
it puts you in this
universe and rewatching it really
solidified it as my favorite show of all
time and it's it's weird because it's a
it's a cop show
and it's predicated on
ram the whole rampart scandal that
happened in the late 90s oh really yeah
you know they closed that whole rampart
division there was this whole crash team
which i think was like
in the show it's called the strike team
but it was these cops who are
are they good cops are the bad cops in
fact in the very first episode the pilot
episode there's this line and there's
this he's trying to catch this pedophile
the main character vic mackey and after
they've interrogated this guy a bunch
and and then finally vic comes in the
room and he goes oh what i get are you
the bad cop and uh vic says
no good cop and bad cop went went home
for the day
i'm a different kind of cop
and that's really it like
yeah he's a bad cop who does good things
or a good cop who does bad things like
you don't really know and then
eventually as the show sort of
unfurls you realize that
it explores the absurdity of good and
bad because we're all good people who do
bad things and we're all bad people who
do good things right yeah but it is a
cop show but it's also high art like
this is
it is a masterpiece that's what yeah i
remember really enjoying it i have not
seen all seven seasons so i'll have to
put that on our watch list well the
funny thing about this ryan is it has
the best ending of any show and that's
what really makes it the best okay it's
such an unexpected ending it's perfect
it's poetic it's exactly what should
happen
but you would never expect this ending
it's and
in the seasons they it's one of these
rare shows you know like some shows are
cash grabs they keep going and going and
like first two seasons were great like a
house of cards or whatever and then all
of a sudden it's like okay
no no no this show
season five is probably the best season
and then season seven is probably the
second best season oh awesome and the
last two episodes are two of the best
episodes in all of tv history
it's awesome
and you fall in love with these
characters and
it's weird because
i feel like you you love the characters
and you hate them
how 3d is that i mean there are people
in our lives where it's like i love you
so much i hate you right now right oh
man i really appreciate the
i don't know the tv shows the movies
that they kind of blur this good and bad
because that's how life is yes like it's
that's real life there's no one who's
100 good there's no one who's 100 bad
and the bad people have their reasons
and the good people have their reasons
but being able to like show that in an
art form like a tv show like i really do
appreciate that and it's i think 88
episodes total so you're talking about
almost 100 hour movie is the way that i
look at it and so you get to know these
people and i remember when it finished
ryan when it ended i felt like i'd lost
something
there was like a week where i was
feeling depressed after i and i had
already seen the show but the very last
scene in the show and you can't you have
to watch all seven seasons in order for
it to be meaningful but
it stuck with me for 14 years there
actually there were two scenes i didn't
remember all the subplots and stuff but
i there were two scenes that
they just rattled me like they stayed in
my bone marrow
for
almost two decades and so it's available
to stream on i i actually i tried to
download it on itunes but it was the old
sd version you know oh it was 4x3 who
wants to watch that
and we are so
privileged man
it was awful and so i went to i i never
had hulu so i went and got the ad free
version of hulu
and i um you can stream it there yeah in
hd and it was it was just right and i
tell you man it by the end of it i felt
haunted i felt exhausted
the characters have stuck with me
michael chiklis who is the lead actor in
there amazing
yeah and then walton goggins play shane
i ran into walton at squirrel our
favorite restaurant once and i walked
past him i looked at him and he looked
at me and he points up and i pointed him
and then i just walked by
um
but uh walton goggins really steals the
show it is a crime that he didn't
because chiklis got an emmy for this but
walton goggins should have got seven
emmys for this he is one of the best
actors in the world wow he's truly truly
amazing so
the other thing i learned ryan is i
found this show because of the art i
found it deeply meaningful and it made
me in a way understand you know when
people come up to us at our live event
or on the street or whatever i really
find your work meaningful like it really
sits with me it resonates with me yeah i
found that with this where i'm like so
appreciative of the of sean ryan the guy
who who created the show i'm so
appreciative to him because
they have stuck with me and i know it's
a cop show but it's not a show about
cops at all they could be cooking like
it's it's about the human experience
and the fact that it happens in this
sort of police precinct it amplifies
that experience but
in fact uh afterward i even dove into
this podcast called the shattered shield
because they talk about each episode and
i found like that was an oh yeah they're
seeing different things about these
characters what a good idea for a
podcast yes wow they dove into every
single episode you can check that out as
well it's called the shattered shield
you can even sort of go along with the
characters i wish i could recommend one
episode the uh here's because yeah the
the the season finale of the fifth
season is a great place not to start but
it's a great episode you gotta start
with the pilot in fact the pilot isn't
indicative of the rest of the show it's
not as good as the rest show but it's
often considered one of the best pilots
in tv history and it's a stunning
shocking pilot when you watch it yeah i
do remember the pilot it's yeah shocking
is a great word yeah but uh that podcast
the shattered shield they do like these
in-depth recaps they do the cast
interviews with people who are actually
on the show like michael chiklis and
and uh and
shane vandrell the walton goggins
character and a bunch of other people as
well
and so um
yeah you got to start with season one if
you're gonna watch it and i will even
say that season one even though it's
great it's the weakest of all seven
seasons and so it's sort of getting
their their footing but by season two
and then season three
oh
i mean it's a whole world that you can't
wait to like get yourself back into yeah
it reminds me of the wire kind of
they're they're kind of similar but the
wire the ending of that
was horrible i didn't think it was
horrible it wasn't nearly as i don't it
wasn't bookended yeah and they they well
they left it on a cliffhanger
beat up for the next season i guess they
probably did that in expecting another
season to come out oh i don't know yeah
that's interesting um
i'll tell you this though the the ending
of the shield
i saw it like there's two or three ways
to interpret it
and the first time i watched i
interpreted it one way yeah but
15 years later i interpreted this one
completely differently even though it's
the same exact scene and i remember it
it's burned into my brain
but uh such a great show the shield yeah
you can find it on an hd on hulu you
know what i remember um the shield most
for what's that uh
you know of course this is like my 19
year old self 20 year old self
um on fx they really pushed the
boundaries with um
nudity
[Laughter]
i remember it being like this big
um almost scandal in a way where like
they were just they were like pushing
right up as far as they could to that
line the funny thing is there might be
like one nipple exactly right exactly
exactly but they they were i'm glad you
mentioned that right because it was on
fx this was the first big show on cable
television oh yeah the very
on regular cable television this is i
mean the sopranos were obviously the
progenitor to this on hbo but on regular
cable tv and so no one really knew what
the rules were because before then you
couldn't even smoke on camera and you
couldn't have prostitutes on camera like
all these different things yeah and they
were like well these aren't actual rules
these are just assume rules and so they
started breaking all these rules and it
made for just i mean the acting the
directing the camera work
it's like having another character the
the camera work uh unbelievable yeah and
i feel like um it's not very gratuitous
either like when they oh like it's very
intentional it's not like well here's
here's some nudity for the sake of it
like it's yeah it it is not gratuitous
it there are shocking scenes but there's
nothing gratuitous yeah shocking in the
sense that like oh my god i didn't know
that was going to happen yeah but of
course it was going to happen you see it
in retrospect like yes
that was going to happen so if you want
to give it a shot you can start with the
pilot season one it's uh man what a
great show
by the way ryan we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are some purchasing rules that can
strengthen or save a relationship what
surprise purchases have personally
annoyed joshua and ryan
how can you hit the calm switch when you
feel overwhelmed plus a million more
questions for the minimalist and if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tik-tok instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalists if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list over at
com on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast
shawn alabama jordan no more social jess
danny unknown em of the immigrant and
the rest of our team i'm joshua fields
milburn reminding you to love people and
use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everybody